it is a scene that people living along
this border have waited for for years a
line of Passenger cars crossed from
Colombia into Venezuela on Sunday
symbolically and practically ending
years of tense relations between the two
countries
it is really a great joy for all
Colombians to be able to move between
the two countries again many of us were
used to moving freely and it made us
very sad that for many years these two
countries were separated so we are very
happy
authorities reopened the tiendita's
bridge on January 1st with a festive by
national ceremony
balloons flew in the air while
government delegations met at the center
of a bridge that until recently had been
blocked by containers placed there by
the Venezuelan Army
today with this formal opening we
fulfilled a political will of President
Nicolas Maduro and Gustavo Petro of
total and transparent openness of the
border with Colombia
like this Colombian president Gustavo
Pedro had announced a normalization of
diplomatic relations with Venezuela
after winning elections in August the
two countries that gradually restored
border crossings and commerce since then
the shared 2200 kilometers border had
been partially closed seven years ago
and completely blocked in 2019 after the
Colombian president Ivan Duke questioned
Venezuelan president Nicolas maduro's
re-election
since then security along the border has
deteriorated with armed groups
controlling the legal transport of goods
and The Exodus of Venezuelan migrants
now people on both sides many by
national are hoping they will benefit
socially and economically
the former Brotherhood is back and this
is what the Venezuelan people want that
we build Brotherhood again that our
Venezuelan Brothers come through with
vehicles that they enter Colombia
because many people have their relatives
on the other side of the Border
trade between the two countries was
worth over 7 billion US Dollars back in
2008 but has collapsed to less than 300
million since while returning to those
levels will be difficult the reopening
has brought relief and hopes for better
times ahead Alessandra Al Jazeera Bogota